so now we move to another democrat uh
this is video of democrat mayor muriel
bowser she is the d.c mayor big democrat
uh things are not going very well in dc
right now
and suddenly she's very upset at the
biden administration because you're not
going to believe what's happening in her
little city because they keep letting
all these illegal illegals in she's
having some problems
the washington post reported last week
that homeless shelters in dc were
filling up
and groups were getting overwhelmed by
these buses that the governors of texas
and and arizona are sending here full of
migrants
how significant is this influx how many
people
well this is a very significant issue we
have for sure called on the federal
government
to work across state lines to prevent
people from really being tricked into
getting on buses
we think they're largely asylum seekers
who are going to final destinations that
are not washington d.c
i worked with the white house to make
sure that fema provided a grant to a
local organization
that is providing services to folks
but i fear that they're being tricked
into nationwide
bus trips when their final destinations
are places all over the united states of
america god these people they're so
ridiculous so first off democrats
basically are for open borders we'll get
to more on that in just a second they
have been tacitly if not
factually welcoming all of these people
we have we have actual numbers on it in
a moment um and now she's suddenly
realizing oh
when they come here it's a problem
because not in my backyard because now
our homeless shelters are being overrun
i love how she says we believe that
they're asylum seekers it doesn't mean
anything it means nothing everyone all
over the world would love to come to the
united states for whatever reason they
might want to come they're an asylum
seeker so she's okay as long as we
disperse these people all over the place
but fortunately we have something called
federalism we have these states rights
and we have competent governors in
places like uh say texas and arizona
which she mentioned and uh florida and
that's what you call that gavin newsom
that's localism people electing their
representatives in their local cities
and states to take care of them so
that's exactly ironically what's
happening here with these red states
they're saying okay you get in here
biden administration isn't going to take
care of the border or you guys are just
going to flood us over what are we going
to do we're going to put them in buses
and send them to d.c and now the
democrat mayor of dc is very upset
because she's okay with open borders
until they show up at her house now we
got a bit of a problem
but you're going dave dave this seems
like a bit much it can't be the joe
biden administration policies that are
causing people to come people that they
know they can't just walk into the
country they know that joe doesn't want
people walking
right into the country that's not how
things work videotape we had a chance to
talk to some of these migrants from
venezuela and they are thinking
president biden take a listen
he's a good president with so much help
that he's given us it's been very
difficult what's happened to us our trip
has been very hard thank god we're here
we thank you for receiving us and
treating us well
look at that look at all of those tacos
wandering over the border
that's dr jill biden that's not me taco
time and they love
joe biden because he's telling him to
come and that's what the administration
has done so we got some info here
because i know you guys like numbers i
don't want to just throw things at you
without any backup information so rnc
research posted this on twitter this is
really fascinating so basically 207
000 illegal immigrants were apprehended
at the border last month that's june the
most apprehensions in dhs history
meanwhile the biden administration
claims that the border is closed so now
before i show you some some other
numbers i'm going to get you some other
numbers in just a sec how that compares
to say years past what's interesting
here is that if you're apprehending 207
000 people that that's good right that
means oh we are protecting the border
now we don't know
this is the key part of this we don't
know actually how many are coming
through but there's plenty of video of
it and now we know in places like dc
when they bust them in they're suddenly
not happy about it so it's hard to track
the illegals who actually come in
because you're not going to believe this
when they walk in they don't go okay i'm
here here there's all my paperwork i'm
here and i'm illegal don't worry about
me i'm going to uh
you know i'm going to sheboygan
so here are some numbers just to give
you a little context of how out of
control these numbers are
so june of this year it was 207 000
apprehensions june of last year 189
thousand now here are the key ones
november of 20 it was 43 000 and june of
20 it was 33 000 so this has exploded
the apprehensions have exploded so what
does that mean the messaging from this
administration is has sort of been
basically come here right the messaging
from that crazy orange man's
administration was do not come so then
less people were inclined to come so
there were way less apprehensions and
there were way less people getting
through so even though we don't know the
exact numbers on the illegals coming
through but you guys have all seen the
videos just wandering through the border
and again muriel bowser is very upset in
dc because they're sending her to her
they're sending her to her hometown
um we know that the numbers are
absolutely exploding and we can
completely uh place the blame at the
doorstep of the democrats on this right
it was not happening under trump it's
one of those things wasn't happening
under trump kind of like inflation
wasn't happening under trump kind of
like gas prices weren't going bananas
under trump kind of like we didn't have
a couple crazy wars under trump etc etc